Are you bored and unmotivated
at your current job,
or unsure about what
you want to do in life?
As we get older,
people always ask us
the most dreaded question:
"What do you do for a living?"
We could either subtle
and work a safe job
that helps pay the bills,
or we could be working actively
to achieve our dreams.
Whichever path you decide to take,
know that reality is rarely ever
that black and white.
In between, you always have a choice
to do what works for you.
Here are some ideal careers to consider,
based on your personality type.
1. Helper.
Are you sociable and people-oriented?
Do you enjoy working in teams,
networking and building connections?
If this sounds like you,
some careers you may
want to look into include:
nursing, teaching,
personal training, human resources,
counseling, social work, retail management,
hospitality and customer service.
People who identify as Helpers
tend to excel in work environments
where they feel needed.
They are great listeners
and have strong interpersonal skills
that help others feel
heard, welcomed, and included.
They are warm, cooperative,
and easy-going nature
makes them reliable workers
who can take care of others well.
2. Builder.
Are you a hands-on learner?
Do you value practicality
and concrete information
over theories and ideas?
If this sounds like you,
then you're a builder.
Some careers you may
want to consider include:
carpentry, piloting, forestry,
farming, firefighting,
police work, massage therapy
electrical work, makeup artistry, cooking,
fashion designing,
and restaurant management.
People with the Builder personality
enjoy projects that get them
moving and grooving.
They dislike sitting all day in a cubicle.
Instead, they like being able
to see the world,
enjoy interacting with people,
and prefer taking action
that makes a difference.
They are great with sensory details,
an observant of their environment.
Builders also tend
to focus on the present,
which makes them great at
taking care of emergencies
and tasks that require immediate attention.
3. Creator.
Do people often call you
creative and original?
Do you enjoy getting lost
and taking a more unconventional route?
If all of this sounds familiar,
then you're a creator.
Some careers you may
be interested in include:
graphic, designing, photography,
writing, filming animation, architect,
art and music production.
Although some people might think
this is a riskier route,
where you end up as a starving artist
who can't provide for yourself,
remember that the world is evolving.
There are many creative industries
and online jobs
that exist today that didn't before,
which helps make these dreams
more approachable.
As Creators ourselves that Psych2go,
we encourage you to follow your heart.
Your strengths as a worker
lies in your ability to see the world
in your own unique lens
and produce work that encourages
beauty, empathy and authenticity.
4. Thinker.
Do you enjoy thinking about
abstract theories and ideas?
Do you like to research
and understand how things work?
If this sounds like you,
then you're a Thinker.
Some ideal careers for you include:
engineering, lab researcher,
computer programming,
medicine, economics, college professor
and market researcher.
Thinkers tend to excel
in work environments
where they can use their superb
analytical and problem-solving skills.
They value efficiency
and enjoy coming up
with shortcuts to systems.
They're tough mindedness
helps them find pleasure
in working through challenges.
Thinkers also value solitude
and get their best work
done in quiet settings
with little to no distractions.
5. Organizer.
Do you enjoy systems,
structure and routine?
Do others often described you
as neat and tidy?
If this sounds like you,
then you're an organizer.
Some ideal careers you might
want to consider include:
library sciences, accounting, programming,
paralegal work, academic administration,
real estate and event coordinating.
Organizers are good at planning ahead,
creating schedules and using Excel sheets.
In work environments, they are the ones
who always come prepared,
meet the deadlines,
give friendly reminders
and keeps everything running smoothly.
Organizers also have great work ethics
and have a high stamina
for working many hours
on detail-oriented tasks.
6. Persuader.
Are you good with your words?
Do you enjoy advocating
for causes you support?
If this sounds familiar,
then you're a persuader.
Some ideal careers
that may suit you include:
financial advising, law, executive work,
public relations, political science
and entrepreneurship.
Persuaders tend to excel
in work environments
where they have the freedom
to make decisions
and execute action plans.
They enjoy being in leadership roles,
and like influencing the public
with their ideas and beliefs.
Persuaders make great debaters
and have the power to change
the way we think about the world.
Many important social movements
have happened throughout history
because of these folks.
So continue to speak up
and make a difference.
Which personality type
do you fall under,
and what's your ideal career?
Hey everybody,
I just want to give a personal
thank you video for you guys
for always supporting Psych2go
and making this all possible for us.
Our vision is to make psychology
as accessible as possible
so that it promotes self-awareness
and it helps you guys grow.
However, we want to make
more content for you guys
and would love your support
in buying one of these bracelets
from our partner, Introvert Palace.
Check out the bracelet.
It's pretty cool,
and it even includes Pluto!
The link to purchase will all
be in the description below
and I hope you guys
have an amazing day.
Bye!
Subtitles by Anh Tran Thi Phuong :D